en los dos últimos vídeos ya platicamos
acerca de la demanda agregada así que
creo que es un buen momento para que
pasemos a la oferta agregada le voy a
poner aquí oferta oferta agregada
agregada agregada y en este vídeo nos
vamos a enfocar específicamente en la
oferta agregada a largo plazo si a largo
plazo y esto es importante plazo porque
o sea en general la oferta agregada la
podemos considerar a largo plazo o a
corto plazo a corto plazo hay muchos
contratos y se haya cosas que están
establecidas ya hay algunos precios
fijos ya tenemos pues también precios
rígidos o cuotas que ya se pagaron
rentas que ya se pagaron entonces a
corto plazo hay muy poco hubo chance
como de negociar sin embargo a largo
plazo esto no pasa esto cambia
completamente porque los contratos se
vencen los precios pues también van
cambiando con el tiempo y por tanto hay
oportunidad de renegociar va entonces
ahorita nos vamos a enfocar en la oferta
agregada a largo plazo y para esto vamos
a graficar
cómo se vería así una vez más tenemos
dos ejes aquí al lado izquierdo tenemos
un eje que tiene que ver con precio ese
precio recuerda es como un precio en un
sentido macroeconómico puede ser un
promedio de precios o el precio de la
canasta básica o algo por el estilo sí y
acá abajo de nuevo vamos a poner el
producto interno bruto real real sale
entonces lo que queremos hacer es
graficar la oferta agregada a largo
plazo pero pues osea recuerda que en
economía una economía todo se trabaja a
partir de modelos que en realidad son
una sobre simplificación de algo que es
muy muy complejo en realidad en el mundo
pues no no viven únicamente a líneas y
puntos en el mundo viven millones de
seres humanos en varios países llegado
nuestros millones de seres humanos
tienen su propia situación cada mente
tiene sus propias cosas que están
sucediendo sus millones de neuronas que
piensan y de repente las personas pues
pueden hacer no sé cosas muy muy
imprevistas o cosas que nadie se
esperaba y entonces pues pueden cambiar
totalmente la idea pero aquí en economía
estamos suponiendo que todo es muy
predecible que pues hay algunas cosas
muy simples de ver que todo está sobre
simplificado y por tanto los economistas
hacen pues algunas suposiciones muy muy
fuertes lo cual es útil a aciertos en
bueno en cierto sentido porque pues si
tenemos unas simplificaciones a lo mejor
demasiadas cosas y se comportan como
dicen esas simplificaciones y entonces
podemos meterle herramientas matemáticas
para predecir fenómenos pero bueno esa
es la parte la parte de los modelos aquí
en la oferta agregada los economistas
hacen la siguiente suposición los
economistas dicen pues a largo plazo el
producto interno bruto real no va a
depender del precio es decir la curva de
oferta agregada a largo plazo se ve así
se ve como una recta vertical
entonces esto de acá pues podría parecer
un poco anti intuitivo verdad porque
pues no sé o sea a lo mejor uno puede
pensar que aumenta la productividad y
entonces esto no se debería de ver así
pero recuerda que todo esto esté térisse
paribus o sea considerando que todo lo
demás es igual a largo plazo no cambia
esta curva de acá estoy acá simplemente
es una fotografía en el tiempo verdad no
nos estamos fijando qué sucede si se
aumenta la productividad o si hay una
nueva tecnología no sé déjame darte
algunos ejemplos por ejemplo para
desplazar esta curva de acá pues puede
ser que aumente la población que de
repente lleguen muchos inmigrantes o que
empiecen a nacer esté más niños más
jóvenes entonces qué sucede si hay más
población y trabajan más entonces esto
se va a desplazar hacia la derecha de
modo similar si hay nuevas formas de
entrenar a la gente y de prepararlos
para sus trabajos
digo usualmente hay un nivel natural de
desempleo un nivel saludable de
desempleo en el cual las personas que
están buscando
y se están preparando más y pues
realmente no estamos forzando el sistema
no le estamos sobrecalentando pero bueno
sí de todas formas encontramos alguna
forma más eficiente de que la gente
pueda conseguir empleo no sea alguna
página de internet o algo por el estilo
entonces habría más trabajo y por tanto
esta curva también sería hacia la
derecha mejoras tecnológicas también
unas mejoras tecnológicas y repentina
puede hacer que se produzca más esto se
vaya a la derecha o no sea un
descubrimiento de nuevos recursos
naturales una nueva mina de oro oa lo
mejor un terreno muy productivo muy
grande que no se consideraba también se
va hacia la derecha pero hay razones por
las cuales también se puede ir hacia la
izquierda o sea aquí todo ha sido muy
positivo y aumenta el producto interno
bruto real pero si hay una guerra si hay
una guerra pues hay muchísimas cosas
malas que pasan con la guerra verdad la
guerra lo que podría hacer es que se
destruyan territorios o que se destruyan
fábricas porque de repente bombardee en
una ciudad y se destruyan oficinas hay
cosas muy feas que pasan en la guerra
es la vida no puede pasar y entonces el
producto interno bruto real disminuiría
esta curva se desplazaría hacia la
izquierda y pues o sea así entonces pues
parece ser un poco antes anti intuitivo
así de lejos que esta curva sea una
curva vertical porque no puede pensar
que hay otras cosas sucediendo en el
mundo pero esas cosas que suceden en el
mundo no están reflejadas aquí en esta
gráfica porque esta gráfica es solo una
fotografía de un momento específico
verdad y entonces pues por lo tanto no
no tendría por qué este cambiarse otra
forma de pensarlo es que pues ve o sea
antes teníamos la demanda agregada y la
demanda agregada tenía sentido que
cambiara y variamos el precio porque la
gente necesita comprar o vender más pero
aquí es la oferta agregada estamos
hablando de la capacidad productiva de
la gente de la capacidad productiva de
un país y entonces realmente todo este
tipo de fenómenos como el ánimo de la
gente o el entusiasmo o la moda no
debería de afectar que tanto se puede
producir o sea que tantos recursos
nación
están aprovechando eso no debería de
cambiar incluso el precio el precio solo
es un numerito aunque los precios se
duplicarán eso va bueno podría afectar
la mente de las personas pero en teoría
la producción debería de ser la misma
porque el precio nada más es un número y
entonces esto no debería de desplazarse
así pues esto es la oferta agregada a
largo plazo nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo para ver la oferta agregada a
corto plazo